I thought a peptide was just an amino acid, it is, a peptide isn't an amino acid.
So a building block of protein, yada yada yada, yes.
So a peptide is a portion, so a peptide is a combination of amino acids.
So a peptide is a portion of a protein.
So a whole protein is named, you know, whatever protein, let's use gluten.
As an example, glee added is the protein in gluten.
So glee added is a very long chain protein, and then a peptide of that is a portion of that,
say 15 amino acids long, or 25 amino acids long, that's a peptide of glee added.
So a peptide, but peptides are active in the body, the peptides that are being used in peptide
therapy are mainly for building up tissue and helping stimulate that building up
in growth of tissue, it's a very unique peptide.
So a peptide of glee added, go back to gluten as an example.
So a peptide of glee added is a portion of the glee added protein.
And it is a, it looks like a certain, a peptide of glee added, maybe similar to a peptide
of a different protein, but it's unique and it uniquely can affect the body.
That's why when you do a food sensitivity test for glee added, you just don't want to
do just glad you, glee added, you want to do the most common peptides of glee added as
well.
That's why I recommend the Syrex test if you're going to do a food sensitivity test because
it tests for the peptides of that thing.
So different peptides and different proteins act on the body in different ways.
That's the whole idea of peptide therapy.
So in all this experimenting and all this research, this certain peptide XYZ is used to help stimulate
growth of, you know, joint capsule tissue.
So it could really help when you're injected in the knee of somebody who's got a damaged
joint capsule or they're not making enough joint fluid, then, you know, you use peptide
therapy to stimulate joint capsule cell production and it could help stimulate its own fluid
and you can prevent this person having to have knee replacement surgery.
So yes, peptides are parts of proteins to stimulate certain action in the body and the
reason why I kind of shied away from them for cancer is that most people, most clinics
that have done peptide therapy for cancer, there's never been any remarkable results with
it.
And there are clinics that are really into peptide therapy for, there are just clinics
that are really super into peptide therapy.
So they're doing a lot of injectable peptides, 99% of the time it's on athletes or people
trying to help with joint erosion or arthritis or trying to prevent, you know, joint replacement
therapy, et cetera.
So if they're, they're mainly for stimulating growth and then will you carry to the next
thing?
Well, this will be good for cancer too because this is so good for this person that brought
back their health and everything.
It's kind of like, well, glutathione has really helped this person with Lyme disease and
oh my gosh, it just really turned them around.
So when my sister has cancer, so I got to give, tell her to take glutathione too.
What works with one morbidity doesn't work with, necessarily, doesn't cross that line.
Now I know there's people that are doing research on that and I'm still waiting for more data
to come out on that.
And so I'm really on the fence with peptide therapy.
I don't want to do anything that could possibly do the wrong thing.